Bran Stark (the kid who tells everyone throughout
season 7 and 8 that he cannot be a lord of
anything because he is the three-eyed raven
now) is okay with becoming a king
and most people think Bran is this good guy
who is the best choice to lead Westeros into
a better future.
Bran who claims he's this powerful Three Eyed
Raven who can see everything,
who can warg into others and who can travel
through the time, does nothing throughout
season 8?
But what if I tell you Bran is the ultimate
villain of Game of Thrones, the ultimate evil
who used his abilities to orchestrate the
entire season 8, made Dany go mad, allowed
Kings Landing and its 1 million people to
burn alive, all so he, the Three-Eyed Raven
could end up on the Throne.
Season 8 Episode 6 made it clear that Bran
knew everything that would happen,
but didn’t do anything to change it or prevent
it.
When Tyrion asked Bran if he would accept
to be their King,
Bran replies with “Why do you think I came
all the way here?”
Later in the episode when Jon Snow says farewell
to his family,
Jon apologizes to Bran for not being there
for him when he needed him,
on which Bran replied with “You were exactly
where you were supposed to be.”
Jon, Tyrion, Daenerys and the rest of the
characters were all chess pieces to him
that he used to get what he wants – the
Throne.
Bran could have told Dany not to go to Dragonstone
back in episode 4 and warn her that Euron
is there waiting for her, but he chose not
to tell her.
Why?
Because he knew Dany was going to lose another
child Rhaegal and closest friend Missandei,
and all of that matched with his plan.
Bran knew everything but chose to tell only
as much as it benefits his ultimate goal.
He manipulated things to turn exactly how
we saw it in season 8.
Bran is the reason Dany went Mad Queen, and
he’s the reason Dany died.
This was confirmed when Bran told to Jon “you
were exactly where you were supposed to be”,
which is sad to me because Dany definitely
did not deserve any of this.
If not for Dany all these Starks including
Jon as well wouldn’t be alive at this point.
If Dany was not so good-hearted and if she
was this Mad Queen all along, she wouldn’t
go north and help the Starks defend their
ancestral home and kingdom.
But she did, she helped them and she saved
them.
She lost a big portion of her armies and friends
in the process and what did she get in return?
The Starks forming an ultimate plan how to
make her mad, get her murdered and win the
Game of Thrones.
Bran Stark is the ultimate villain.
Littlefinger and Varys were right when they
said “knowledge is power”, and the one
with most knowledge (Bran) wins.
Bran knows everything that’s happened, everything
that’s happening, and everything that will
happen.
Bran, the good honorable Stark died in that
cave and became the Three-Eyed Raven.
When Benjen comes in out of nowhere and rescues
Bran and Meera, Meera asks Benjen why did
he rescue them,
he answered because the Three-Eyed Raven requested
him.
When Meera counters that with saying that
the three-eyed raven just died, Benjen answered
''he lives again'',
confirming Bran is the three-eyed raven
which Bran confirmed himself over and over
again in seasons 7 and 8.
Why is this important to highlight?
Well, because every Three-Eyed Ravens that
ever existed and the current three-eyed raven
as well, Bran, has the ability of greensight
which gives you the power to perceive the
past, present and future
through visions and time travel with ease.
Bran already had great power and could see
future before even becoming the Three-Eyed
Raven,
of course not as clearly as he could later
on, but still he had that power.
Remember back in season 2, Bran had strange
dreams that he would talk about with Osha.
This time he reveals her a dream about the
sea flooding Winterfell and drowning Winterfell
and its people, even going as far to highlight
Ser Rodrik Cassel especially.
Indeed, soon after that, Winterfell is attacked
by Theon Greyjoy and the Iron Born.
Rodrick is captured and beheaded.
Osha then tells Bran that his dream came true,
the Iron Islands (represented as the sea in
the dream) have come to Winterfell with their
Drowned god to drown it.
Someone who also had the ability of greensight
was Jojen Reed
and he already knew how to see it clearly.
When explaining the greensight to Bran he
tells him that they are visions of the past,
present and future.
We see how clear Jojen can see the future
when he brushes off the threats to kill him
of Nights Watch traitors while being captured
at Craster's Keep, saying he has already seen
his death in a vision and it won't be now,
as he sees a vision of his hand on fire.
Indeed, he died by fire when they reached
the Three-Eyed Ravens cave.
Why I'm telling you all of this is just for
you to understand that Bran,
who grew far more powerful than Jojen, Bran
was definitely able to see everything that
was going to happen in the future, he's seen
it all play out before it did.
Bran knew the Night King would come to him
and he knew Arya would come and save him.
That's why he gave her Valyrian steel dagger.
Bran started seeing glimpses of past and future
in season 4, something which Bran drastically
improved over the years, especially after
becoming the Three-Eyed Raven.
Bran saw Drogon flying above Kings Landing
about to burn it down and even saw the aftermath
of Drogon and his burning of Kings Landing.
All of this he saw from his first vision ever,
which was a long time ago when he wasn’t
as powerful as he is now years later.
This was much before he even became the Three-Eyed
Raven.
He also saw a wildfire vision before Cersei
blew the Sept of Baelor.
Not only is it safe to say, but this is an
actual evidence supporting the fact that Bran
knew
what would happen to Kings Landing before
it actually happened, but chose to not change
anything,
chose to stay silent and chose 1 million people
to die, all so he could become the king.
Everyone from Arya to Jon were just puppets
for Bran
and he used them to orchestrate the end we’ve
got.
Bran orchestrated the deaths of the Night
King as well as of Dany
and ensured he would end up on the Throne.
Bran isn’t Bran Stark anymore, Bran died
in that Cave
when the old three-eyed Raven transferred
his own mind to Bran's he is the Three-Eyed
Raven
and his only goal was to end on the Iron Throne
through the power of seeing past, present
and future, through orchestrating future events
which he did by carefully choosing what to
say and what not to say.
The Night King wasn't coming after all humanity,
he was coming for the Three-Eyed Raven which
Bran confirmed in season 8 episode 3.
Bran says he is coming for him because he
is worlds memory and the Night King wants
to erase worlds memory, but I am convinced
the Night King was coming for this three-eyed
raven
to save humanity from such great evil taking
over, but he failed.
The first future event Bran orchestrated was
the fall of the Night King by giving Arya
the Valyrian steel dagger which he knew Arya
would later use to kill the Night King in
that very same spot.
In the Game of Thrones among the living though,
Bran was as useless as he could get
but he actually wasn't.
It's a fact that Bran can see the future and
manipulate it.
Bran's visions prove it, the ending proves
it, and Bran confirms it by saying ''why do
you think I came all this way''
to Tyrion when he asks him if he will be their
king.
But let's imagine Bran cannot see the future
and those glimpses of the future that he can
see
and what he saw are truly only glimpses
and he cannot use them to tell what’s going
to happen
which definitely isn’t because he kind of
confirmed he can see and orchestrate the future
by giving Arya the Valyrian steel dagger
on the same place that would later be used
to kill the Night King and by telling Tyrion
that he knew he would be chosen a king
and by telling Jon that he was exactly where
he was supposed to be.
David Benioff also said that Bran said “thank
you” to Theon
because Bran knew what was going to happen,
kind of confirming that Bran has seen everything
and knows everything that’s going to happen
in the future.
But for the sake of the argument, let’s
say that’s true,
let’s say Bran cannot see and orchestrate
the future.
It still doesn’t change a fact that he could
have prevented the burning of Kings Landing.
Bran said it himself that he can see everything
that’s happened and everything that is happening.
So why didn’t he warg into Dany or Drogon
and stopped that madness
and prevent 1 million people from dying?
Or why didn’t he warn Dany that Euron is
waiting for her at Dragonstone, preventing
him from killing Dany’s dragon and best
friend?
He was there at the war council just before
she went to Dragonstone.
Oh yes, I forgot, it all had to happen, it
was in fact orchestrated by Bran so he could
get the Throne...
Bran’s been manipulating events throughout
the entire season 8 that would get him to
this point.
Bran is the final villain of the story.
Bran manipulated Sam into telling Jon the
truth
specifically after Dany had just told Sam
she'd burned his father and brother alive.
Bran did this on purpose knowing Sam would
not only reveal to Jon the truth,
but also tell Jon that she is not the best
choice for the people of Westeros,
but more importantly, Bran knew Jon wouldn't
continue his relationship with Dany after
finding out the truth and Dany would become
more paranoid after learning Jon has the best
claim to the throne.
And let's face it, that's the only reason
Jon found out the truth about his parents
Rhaegar and Lyanna, only so Jon would end
his relationship with Dany and wouldn't give
Dany the affection she needed after losing
her children, her armies and her advisors.
The only thing it would give Dany is paranoia.
Bran also knew that Jon was going to tell
the truth to his family, Arya and Sansa,
and Bran knew Sansa didn’t like Dany and
she’s Littlefinger’s student.
He knew Sansa would start scheming to overthrow
Dany by using Jon’s claim -- and he knew
that this way the truth behind Jon’s true
parentage and the claim would spread.
Bran tells to Sam to tell the truth to Jon,
Jon tells the truth to his family, Sansa tells
it to Tyrion, Tyrion tells it to Varys and
Varys informs all the seven kingdoms.
The truth spreads, Dany’s own advisors start
plotting behind her back,
which makes Dany grow more and more paranoid.
Bran deliberately doesn't warn Dany how Euron
is waiting for her at Dragonstone
even though he can see everything, which leads
to Dany losing Rhaegal and Missandei,
all of this making Dany more frustrated and
ultimately turning her mad which leads to
her burning the entire city and all the innocent.
Jon is then left with no choice, but to kill
her and Jon himself must be punished for this.
Also, that scene where Jaime asks Bran why
didn’t he tell everyone else what he did
to him, on which Bran replies “you wouldn’t
be able to help us in this fight if I let
them murder
you first”.
Jaime didn’t do anything of great importance
in the battle for Winterfell,
he did not have any role in killing the Night
King,
he did not kill any White Walkers which would
reduce the Night King’s army during the
battle.
All he did was fighting wights, like everyone
else in the living army.
So he did not help at all during this fight,
at least not more than any other soldier.
He did something significant in the other
fight though,
the fight for Kings Landing when he rang the
hell bells that for some reason made Dany
go crazy,
so that must have been the help Bran saw Jaime
would provide in the future,
also seemingly seeing that right after this,
he would be killed by bricks.
All the events Bran manipulated led to the
outcome he’s been working on this entire
season,
Bran Stark becomes the King.
Bran, the one with the most knowledge and
thus the most power,
wins the Game of Thrones.
He was behind everything that happened in
season 8.
Not so bad of an ending after all -- if it
was well written
and if Bran had any other line other than
“I don’t want anything really.
I can’t be the lord of Winterfell I’m
the three-eyed raven now” and if the execution
was not so terrible
and if only they did not make Dany go from
the ultimate savior to the ultimate mad queen
in the span of 1 episode.
In fact, it’s how George RR Martin’s books
will also end
as they said multiple times that the ending
will be the same,
but the journey to get there will be quite
different,
and the journey is exactly what was so disappointing
here.
In the books, we already have clues that Bran,
the Three-Eyed Raven is evil.
One of the visions Melisandre sees in the
flames is about a 'wooden face, corpse white'
with a thousand red eyes accompanied by a
boy with a wolfs face,
and Melisandre wonders if this is THE enemy.
Her vision is obviously about the old three-eyed
raven teaching Bran how to become him
and she seems to think they are the real enemy.
Anyways, Dany going mad, Bran becoming the
King,
and everything else could have been written
so that all of this would make sense.
More importantly, it should not have been
rushed,
there should have been more episodes and more
seasons to wrap it all up nicely.
Even HBO knew it and offered Dan and David
unlimited budget to do 10 seasons, which they
refused.
Instead, we got
rushed and poorly written season where the
ending is nowhere near bittersweet, only bitter.
Bran did learn how to see things better and
what did he choose to do with the information?
He chose to sit in his wheelchair, sacrifice
everyone else,
orchestrate things and events to lead him
and his family into ultimate victory in the
Game of Thrones.
They chose an evil man to be their king, a
guy who manipulated the entire plot just to
be a king.
''Why do you think I came all this way'' disgusts
me, it disgusts me that he knew it all along.
What a great king Westeros has right now,
a king that did not care to stop Dany from
burning down Kings Landing and killing 1 million
people.
Bran manipulated the events to make Dany mad
so Jon would be forced to kill her.
This way Dany is obviously dead and cannot
be the Queen while Jon takes the black for
killing her
which makes him no longer a legitimate heir
to the throne.
Only after this - Bran decided to reveal that
he knew and saw all this play out already
as he orchestrated it all by telling some
little, but more importantly not telling more.
Bran basically used his all-seeing ability
of past, present, and future to help only
him and his family
(not including Jon Snow because as he said
himself, he doesn't see Jon as his brother),
ensuring his family comes at the top at the
end, instead of using it at all for the benefit
of others to save others... if you ask me,
that makes Bran Stark the ultimate villain
of Game of Thrones.
No human rules the Six Kingdoms, The Three-Eyed
Raven does.
The final episode of Game of Thrones and Bran's
two responses,
firstly to Tyrion when asked if he would like
to be their king ''why do you think I came
all this way'' and second to Jon when Jon
apologized for not being there for him ''you
were exactly where you were supposed to be''
proved he saw everything and orchestrated
everything.
He’s the reason Kings Landing burned down,
he is the reason Dany lost everything and
turned mad,
all so Jon would have to kill her, eliminating
them both from the Iron Throne and taking
it for himself.
Bran Stark, the Three-Eyed Raven is the ultimate
villain of Game of Thrones.